- [Voiceover] A farmer used
fence posts to build a fence
for Hazel Horse and Pauly Pony.
The farmer used 26 fence posts
to build Hazel Horse's fence
and 19 fence posts
to build Pauly Pony's fence.
How many fence posts did
the farmer use in all?
If you like, I encourage
you to pause the video
and try to figure it out.
I'm assuming you have tried it,
so let's think it through together.
Whenever you think about
a word problem like this,
what are they asking?
What's the story in our head?
A farmer is building fence
posts for two different horses,
Hazel Horse and Pauly Pony.
There's even a picture of Hazel
Horse here and Pauly Pony.
They look very similar.
The farmer used 26 fence posts
to build Hazel Horse's fence,
so that's these 26 fence
posts right over here.
These are the 26 fence posts
for Hazel Horse's fence.
I haven't counted it, but I'll
just take their word for it
that there are 26 here,
and then 19 fence posts
to build Pauly Pony's fence.
These are 19 fence posts right over here.
How many fence posts did
the farmer use in all?
In all, so what do they want us to do?
Do they want us to add or
subtract these numbers?
Well, they're looking at "in all."
How many total fence
posts did the farmer use?
Well, the total is how many used
in Hazel's fence and Pauly's fence,
so we should add these two numbers.
We're going to add 26 plus
the 19, or let me see.
The 26 is in that brownish color, 26.
That's the 26 fence posts to
build Hazel Horse's fence,
and we're going to add that to 19.
We're going to add that to 19,
so 26 for Hazel Horse
and then 19 for Pauly Pony.
We want to add them because we're saying
how many fence posts were used in all,
or in Hazel's and Pauly's fences.
Let's add these two together.
First, let's go to the ones place.
Six ones plus nine ones is 15 ones,
but we only can write one digit here,
so 15 ones is the same thing
as five ones and one 10, right?
15 is just one 10 and five ones,
so we've essentially
regrouped those 10 ones
as one 10 right over here,
or as some people say,
you carry the one, but
that's all it's saying.
We're saying six plus nine is 15.
15 is five ones and one 10.
We wrote that one 10 in the tens place,
and then one 10 plus two 10s plus one 10.
Well, the one plus two plus one is four,
so it's going to be four 10s, so 45.
How many fence posts used in all?
45.
Now, some of you all that
might have somehow tried
to maybe subtract the 19 from 26,
that would have been
what you would have done
if they said, "How many more
fence posts did the farmer use
"for Hazel's fence than for Pauly's?"
Then, you would subtract 19
from 26 to find the difference,
but they didn't ask us how
many more fence posts were used
for Hazel than for Pauly, or
how many fewer fence posts
were used for Pauly than Hazel.
They didn't ask us that.
They said, "How many fence posts
did the farmer use in all,"
and that's why we added.